what's going on in Toledo is what's
important right now WTOL and this is how
Toledo is covering for everything for
the kids you're gonna love this Center
good morning CPS students it is testing
week and it's time to slay all day stay
woke
beyond fleek and get that Gucci
breakfast goals it's cute no it's not
this is uh this is insulting to everyone
everyone to everyone right that here's
the way we're gonna stop many times okay
and every time you stop start over
rewind a little bit don't start from the
beginning but we're winding realize
you're getting that fleek sleep and if
you guys are doing some opiates remember
this is lamilton is more lit that
happened [ __ ] fentanyl laced cocaine
that's a real problem
yeah hey what are you doing man this is
what the script says local news has
officially become worse than the way it
was portrayed in the film Network like
if it had just come to you know the way
Network said it was gonna go it would
have a more integrity more integrity yes
shittiest part is they were [ __ ]
excited they loved it this is for they
letting their hair down oh yeah they
think they're being cute [ __ ] excited
about yes and I know Wednesday we can do
this oh so fun like Brian I mean do you
know any you have a 16 year old cousin
can can they help us out with us they're
texting their friends going I think this
is the morning you're gonna wanna watch
just put it on when we come back from
commercial
make sure the volumes up her dress is
awful I want to [ __ ] her for some
reasons because she is so attainable a
hundred percent
Toledo eight and a half yes she's the
queen of Toledo in Toledo forget it
she's in LA three dogs I was just gonna
throw mud in front of it and hope it
worked for a [ __ ] minor league
baseball team she's getting her black
her back blown out by the right fielder
for the mud head he's like yeah I don't
care
I'm only here two months out of the
yeah play in Japan so I can make a
little bit standing out there with [ __ ]
on the front of his uniform and that was
lit okay putting an ice pack on your
dumper is lit we're only five seconds
into this poor woman's news broadcast
and this is where scoffs it's [ __ ]
stupid
it's cute oh man this is the [ __ ] well
luckily there are other departments of
the night diode to take it a little bit
more serious when I agree with Chinese
policy which is just like monitoring
after you see this John would not
tolerate this no take oh the supreme
leader is literally the best like the
[ __ ] end all of them you ever seen
that woman that does the news she's like
late the Tom Brokaw yeah the pink late
she's the trusted one in North Korea his
other name the trusted or basically yes
he's the one that they go to that the
state loves and I mean I really think
we're looking at all this whole [ __ ]
government controlling everything really
wrong I know there is a case to be made
for it they it's consistency yeah this
lady in pink she never does any of this
ridiculous Instagram talk she's
approached Kim jong-un though he well
you know called it down the middle I
don't think she calls it up I don't
think this lady calls it like she sees
it oh I was taking no prisoners actually
she's taking many prisoners otto
warmbier kind of what they do is take
prisoner tons of them well I think it's
a good time to go there and now if
you're an American yeah talking yeah you
could probably go there just don't [ __ ]
up yeah you don't look crooked at a
statue right or chew gum is it one of
those Asian countries right um no I
don't know Singapore you can't spit on
the sidewalk is that what it is yeah all
right let's I apologize I listen let's
get it back I'm so sorry
so on stay woke beyond fleek and get
that Gucci breakfast goals
say bye Felisha to that testing stress
weather's gonna be turned right Chris
yeah
[Music]
you wanna put my [ __ ] hand through
the back of your head Yas Queen Chris
doing poppers behind a train in Central
Park
he's going all sucking off I'll suck
your dick better than anybody I want you
to pop in my mouth sailor I mean really
give me a load of my mouth I'm a [ __ ] do
you know the embarrassment these are all
these dudes have kids they all have kids
they have families they're in Toledo and
their kids have to go to school knowing
that the dad just went on TV and when
yeah hey is your dad Chris the
weatherman from WTOL I got a forecast
for you I'm gonna [ __ ] this newscast
requires not I'll see you at 3 o'clock
and I'm gonna beat you up beat you up
all day very long I'm gonna just follow
you class to class every time that bell
rings yeah it's a pound every time it's
partially cloudy I'm making a joke you
better hope the Sun stays out this guy
had some funny stuff yes he was just
waiting there - the anticipation was
she's like saying he goes yeah [ __ ] the
what at the sports guy he's got to be
involved he said they're all involved I
haven't seen that much of it didn't
watch the whole thing no I think the
sports guy was let go Hanako matter if
you remember that commercial the
honeycombs yeah and then the traffic I
just popped up and he was all like going
out get down here lick my [ __ ]
we shouldn't hire the guy from Chicago
oh yeah that guy's [ __ ] he's not guys
real wild card Erica there's gonna be
turn right Chris yeah gonna be lit
during testing week a hundo pee chance
of success hundo got me uh hon dopey I
got a suit I gotta see what he's
learning into right now he turns into
that laughs I saw a Hondo pee isn't even
a thing 100% no but nobody says a hundo
I do what yeah Jim doesn't law I'm gonna
pay no they say like you could say like
100
one hundred hundred pay but I've never
heard a hundo P Jim said it last week he
got upstaged at the cellar he came
upstairs ago how early it was humma P
hundo P where the kids and all like oh
my god never hurt okay but I've paid one
two all right
the words don't make sense like Jim said
that and I was all like leave a mark
that was Vila yeah I made that record
scratch sound effect and then because
they tested let's go back to these guys
never have your career journalist
success you've got this kids Steve how
about that traffic are we looking okay
better than okay we're talking turn o mo
won't be an issue no truck this is where
this gentleman is hey man I ain't doing
this [ __ ] right before this is really
gonna make me [ __ ] do this [ __ ] man
I served in Iraq you ain't making me do
this [ __ ] there's no way this black
gentleman was happy about this yeah he's
enjoying its foam oh it doesn't even
make sense that he just said FOMO like
fear miss you know what they didn't say
anything about having a fear of missing
it anything it makes sense if you go
back okay all right I believe you Travis
let's go back to Oh God what is that
that's that's a car D B's Oh cause you
know that most of this is snapping my
pee-hole shut they she really cardi B he
should [ __ ] drugged him and robbed
them yeah oh yeah talk about car D as
well Barney are we lookin okay we're
talking turn o mo won't be an issue
no traffic problems around oh I thought
he was just saying Turk FOMO won't be an
issue I thought he just said turn in
FOMO just because no like we're talking
turn FOMO won't be an issue
oh man and at this point they [ __ ] to
Lee tankers are just sitting at their
desk like it's Rocking this is happening
this is it checking their social media
like oh my god
I can't wait for the retweets there's no
way we're gonna get pissed all over at a
Sirius radio show I hope they get the
same tweet Salman Rushdie got the first
tweet started to come in they were like
well luckily it's just local news so
it's not like this is gonna go Nash's a
contained fire yeah I tweeted this video
that's right and a lot of people they
loved it
well it went it went a lot of people
were tweeting it out not just me
obviously getting a negative I hope no
not at all this is for the kids I don't
know if the kids bought in as much as
they felt I disagree also I think the
reason that I didn't understand what was
being here under selling the youth of
America thank you yes hmm I think that a
lot of the reason I want to slam my head
into the TV like the [ __ ] what's the
Will Smith movie where they're all
zombies I well I am no but if you think
what's the blindfold movie blind box
these guys you [ __ ] commit suicide
you see my eyes get [ __ ] weird oh man
I want to see where this goes because
there's definitely a sports guy who's
like I [ __ ] doing it here's this is
Sam Elliot it's this guy or girl for
Bradley Cooper movie by the way he had
no place in that movie I've never even
saw it was not it was not good I want to
see it for dice the ice was great nice
isn't it dice was amazing in it but Sam
Elliot made no really he played Bradley
Cooper's brother Travis tried to make
heads or tails out of it but Travis is a
he's a move Travis is a movie [ __ ] use
for a lot of my friends shut up you
movie cop Travis is a total movie cuck
he comes in and he help defend anything
he paid a ticket to see it was a no the
story was good he was defending walking
dead way past anybody should have been
watching that show I don't anymore it
was you got to be patient through the
storytelling I was he's a movie cocky
do you like storytelling I mean I could
appreciate it sure you hung on too long
though right I did yeah is it good now
no you still think you're a movie cook
with stars born no it's a good movie see
movie got total movie total movie cut I
told him I said the only reason he likes
that movies because the song and then
you hear the song and you're like
I like this I guess I like the movie but
that's not true it's just the song is
good also Bradley Cooper isn't that good
of a singer and everybody saying he is
although Travis is over there going it's
getting cut it was pretty good it was a
good structure really good I mind
because I don't think I say that well
you sound like it give any term how do
you feel about this this low are you
gonna defend these local news anchors oh
god no no I few don't mind I'd like to
get back to the good time you're right
let's rewind a little bit more don't run
at all but there's this great moment
that I want you guys to pick up on and
it's the moment that this traffic guy
takes over so go before he takes over
because when he says oh Koror dominates
but he pauses and he chuckles a little
bit and that's the moment that none of
these people have had everybody else
thinks they're being cool this guy has a
moment where he goes oh no but then he
keeps going anyway man I hope the
brothers back in Cleveland and sing this
[ __ ] yeah that brings in where he goes
no that was trying to be a cool those
that because their conscience is kicking
in no if he is trying to be cool that's
because he knows like oh no I don't
think this is cool and then he has to
kick in with a I think any black for
someone no this is not cool okay I
disagree I think this is very very urban
she just stops local Toledo gang members
from committing crime got them they came
together on a project the [ __ ] hurting
each other let's save the community
center your weapon is your mind right
I'm afraid of what you can accomplish
how good would it be one of those movies
the boys turn around and bonded over
stabbing the teacher
you only make it twenty three thousand
years Michelle Pfeiffer's going well
would you do your homework if I gave you
a candy bar they just beat the [ __ ] out
of it you ain't no good yeah we have
type 2 diabetes
yeah hey nobody talk like that I'm gonna
give me sugar foot her accent was so bad
in that movie what if I change to a
roller coaster oh yeah what
man white Savior that was like the
original way there's nothing whitey
loves more than a [ __ ] white hero oh
just go saving underprivileged oh yeah
clean it up white style yeah bye
trickery I'm gonna get you into school
via trickery you can find a video at one
point of one of her Courtney beef
answers that movie of her of action in
that let's watch the rest this dude's
name but her accent is not good not good
well yeah we'll visit that dangerous
mind the classic that's where gangsta's
paradise came from yeah won't be an
issue
no traffic problems around any t feet at
schools to keep you from taking those
tests so get a good night's sleep do
your best in fact be extra extra
we here at WTOL rvz pause for a second
what the hell is the weatherman smilin
can you see [ __ ] that look that that
literally is I did a poppers reference
I'll do another
that's a poppers lair yes I just got but
[ __ ] right guy that sets up the cameras
he goes right now my [ __ ] slowly
closing back to its normal size do you
think they have to train him don't say
what you think did you read the prompter
yes you know I'm a real live [ __ ] right I
know but you're so goddamn good at the
weather you're just so goddamn good at
[ __ ] he's all of it he's you guys the
best meteorologists this is like major
league they've got all the castaways to
come and do the Toledo news he's doing
his thinking smile and they're going oh
no no no I want to suck dick not during
the gabbai segment
he's bopping around he looks stoned yeah
the anchor is bonding I hate to say it
guys that is a abducted child can't go
anywhere face this is I finally have my
trophy alone to myself smile see you're
thinking that this is this is the the
incarnation of be from abducted in plain
sight this is what starts soon yeah I
just had sex with an entire family
well I relieved him as I told me the
weather very very read he doesn't know
what to do with this yeah not really
weird whose idea with this which is the
PD or to one of them ago that would be
funny in the old one yes I bet one per
day brought it up to one of the top to
one of the middle ones and they're like
oh my god that would be on a Monday I
think the kids are really like they go
crazy for that cuz they're all on board
here
kids love local news and we're never to
feel like we're talking to them right no
and I'll tell you what nobody will do
make fun of us for this at all she's hot
though that woman is she is her dress
stinks yeah I love it yeah love her
[ __ ] Talbots dress $59 I'll lift one
of those heavy tits right off the top
yeah I do too [ __ ] yeah big teardrops
suck away but don't you think you guys
don't have a chat with the weather man
standing right there yeah I have a
feeling he's gonna watch oh that's
that's a [ __ ] let me let me beat in
the corner smile he goes like this this
is the weather man's thing he walks
ready he goes gay straight I just like
to watch holes a hole and it's all good
to me [ __ ] this guy's so crazy I rehire
me coz because he invented his father
invented double double da floor system
my dad may have invented that but I'm
gonna tell you guys something I am
feeling sexual hi I'm Ken Doppler and I
wanna [ __ ] gay straight I'm just here
for the sex I don't give a [ __ ] about
the weather as long as it's coming he's
just a sexual dude yeah in a good
night's sleep do your best in fact be
extra extra we here at WTOL RV proud of
you students are going for HIV test you
might be dying
yeah the end of that you could feel when
they were like and we're clear they're
only what do we just is embarrassing
yeah [ __ ] do I feel prouder after
starring in a scat film wiping [ __ ] off
your chest you good yeah yes not the
work Jenner was it sexy it's got 23
thousand views how many this this
version does I mean there were many many
versions yeah I don't know how many how
many just the the version that I tweeted
was actually the original version 3.9
million words that from yesterday oh I
mean it just came out yes this hurt
where did you go just 3.9 million views
dude when you get something on Twitter
and it goes viral like because now on
Twitter you could just see the person
who originally posted it and you can
tweet their video without like
retweeting and stuff so the video just
comes up in my tweet yeah but it's this
you know gone girl or whoever she is is
the first person who tweeted it so all
those views are going to hers and so
it's yeah it's got like I love a million
views and the girl that put it up
of course her name is space goth cui Xia
and she says I cannot believe yes that's
what perfect you can't [ __ ] write
that that she's the one she's like mom
you left the news on and she's like what
is this this is so embarrassing she just
posted it just being like to her friends
I guess it was ridiculous this is so
stupid and then they're like hey can you
not sure that W - I was like hey can you
shut up and she's like what do I have
3,000 followers it's not that big of a
deal
4 million views later she's got a knife
and a profile here's the problem they're
gonna try to do it again with something
else of course they are yeah of course
yeah we went viral
hey JD in Toledo let's talk to a local
boy yeah take my hands mop sorry
actually this is all right I'm sorry I
believe you have a gay weatherman
tacking back this is JD this is Jim this
is JD and talento ok cool what's not
welcome yeah oh it's Aledo no she's hot
I think cleaner girls are my favorite
girls in the planet are you saying look
up the morning girls of Toledo 5 no
Toledo 5 saying she's a 5 oh she is a
lookit
WTO ELLs evening anchor Christie now
she's a Toledo ten do you watch the
Morning News they're in Toronto in
cielito JD absolutely and do they
usually do high jinks like this it's
[ __ ] up what's her name Christie
lectures Rob's panicking Rob is looking
at Robbie's email ascending eben-emael
heard you are hot send pics with the
morning no I'm pretty but the other ones
man out man I'm a sucker for a brunette
I like the evening sorry good answer why
your marriage Roberto that's true yeah
oh whoa wait was it the middle picture
because some cans yeah she's very busty
that's why she yes she go in the morning
Wow no no I already call it till I die
no you're going to Talbots with the
other one oh no we'll go to the outlet
store quickly and then I'll drop her
back off all right that's fine then yeah
dude Christy what's up yeah both hot
yeah you're welcome thank you very much
so JD did you enjoy your newscasters
kind of talking to the kids as a young
man taking tests did you feel like
they're on your side
as a father of two I felt like they were
ready for their day good good that's
excellent thank you buddy
I mean it's gotta be so tough what to
just be a regular person on that that
works at Toledo the tll 11 and you're
like I don't this isn't a good idea yeah
and they don't listen to you
right cuz yeah yeah or you know why am I
even saying it the anchors are excited
why would you be excited this is gonna
turn out so poorly yeah is that her
husband Kristy Lee uh
that's what happens don't you hate when
you see a pretty girl she's married not
some lovely like I can't yeah honestly
yeah you know that's what happens when
you go to Toledo she could she could do
a lot better yeah Wow
you know but she's in Toledo so it's
she's in Toledo so that guys probably
got a he's got a stable job you know in
crowd she probably knew him since high
school yeah who knows where she was
raised a lot of times you're not raised
well you're doing the local news yeah
they're just like you know they move
from town to town basically the carnies
of journalism that's why they have
little accent know that I'm an accent
yeah because they're all from [ __ ]
you know they live in Phoenix but
they're originally from that's what
everybody says right isn't the isn't the
preferred news accent the Denver accent
because it really is you know Sam I'm
glad you brought that up
millions Denver Colorado's do a lot of
interesting things and you should be on
legal weed and you fix breaks you should
hear the way we talk and we talk
so we enunciate perfectly yeah Eddie I
met Paul Giamatti yeah oh yeah you have
you since I you've met him that's pretty
impressive that's pretty much it yeah
they keep us separated they do yeah well
of course you're on opposite ends of the
spectrum
yeah and I'm very method I was gonna say
one's the enemy and one isn't but who
knows is the animator 9 p.m. Sundays on
Showtime does it start this week it's
dude episode 3 this week man
what it already started thanks Sam [ __ ]
hey that's hurtful right now he's gonna
pretend he watches it I got three
episodes to watch I'm pretty excited for
Russell mania I can't XD I guess yeah
but I'll bet that I bet that you're not
as excited as your boy Michael che is
he's in the room he's in the [ __ ] all
did you how did you feel when you found
out because that was very tense that
press conference it was a part of a
moment of bliss on Monday night was very
very uncomfortable very to see them both
ready to preparing to wrestle to wrestle
to fight for their lives but your guy
who used to we used to be a wrestling
buddy you used to go to shows with him
yeah now this is where I leave him he's
in the battle royal I didn't know this
was coming I knew they were working with
the WWE he and I had talked like about
what they were gonna do mm-hmm
and I thought it's gonna be just just in
the rumble so now I'm interested to see
what they do with che yeah yeah but if
he hits them like [ __ ] 2 cold Scorpio
leaves Weekend Update it becomes a
wrestler dude I almost want to text and
be like do dress up like 2 cold Scorpio
or flash funk icons with gold such a
good song he's realized Michael che is
an aerial expert did you learn these
skills with moonsault off the top rope
yeah by the way go background this is
why I love [ __ ] you to look at the
top of video recommended 12 times Vince
McMahon got so emotional he cried for
real
somebody put together yeah someone's
wife was like come on dinner's ready
goes hold on I'm getting this last
moment in I only have nine crimes I got
to find three more let me tell you
something if I is that we're popping up
on a video next to me I'd go like all
right I'll hang out and watch that yeah
I'd like to see when Vince cried for
real this is how the wormhole start oh
yeah did you start looking at you're
like [ __ ] it all right I'll go down this
hole and then the next one is a video
George the animal Steele on Andre the
Giant's enemies list yeah let me check
that out yeah I want to know I want to
know what George you do bears the most
effective algorithm I'm gonna [ __ ] up
your day go oh yeah it does it's really
really good all right I bet you didn't
even know this video exists you're like
yeah I want to watch all of heat with
subtitles for some reason why did this
come up but isn't it funny that somebody
found
Vince McMahon crying videos this is
amazing top 12 yeah there's about 40 out
there I went through all of them yeah
and I found the best one these are my 12
favorites were the most masculine man
crying yeah he doesn't show a lot of
emotion no he doesn't what's it like
being in a room alone with them I have
not been in a room alone with him you've
been in a room with him though yeah one
two limbs terrifying
we were at raw 1000 he had everybody
wore tuxes all the announcers were tuxes
and I was like a last-minute decision
but you know you got to be ready so I
showed up in my tux and everything Sam
bond yeah exactly I look like a million
bucks yeah but we're a couple of the
announcers we're sitting there in the
hallway backstage at the Barclays Center
and we don't know he's in the room
behind us the door just opens Vince
walks out and we're like uh and then he
just looks around he goes my guys in
tuxes love it and he just keeps walking
and I'm like [ __ ] yeah yeah okay you
make a snide remark to him yeah I did I
said when you keep your opinions to
yourself smart move that's a likes that
yeah yeah yeah the guy's like that like
to be challenged yeah yeah yeah in front
of their employees especially by people
who just showed up that aren't there
normally they're just yeah so you grab
power exactly yeah I'm gonna try that
man you're a Viking with that beard
thank you taking what you want thank you
very very much respect it we should take
a break yeah we have Billy Corbin and we
have Chris Jericho yeah I mean you're a
wrestling fan huh four can a and then
Sam that was V mean yeah yeah Chris in
New Jersey what's up good evening good
evening
hey Sammy you should show Dan Soder the
Utah House of Representatives rap video
this reminds me of that yeah that's that
that is the callback yeah that I felt -
have you ever seen The Fresh Prince of
bills here it's really cute we're not
gonna do a full breakdown cuz we do have
to go to break we can't we don't have
enough time yeah we still got to do that
too right we still gotta check out the
honeycomb hideout but let's watch let's
watch it and try not to stop it it's
only a minute long you know we've spent
hours watching this let's try it
this is a story all about right there in
the book is where they saw there was
multiple people that they go what do you
want me to do like I'm mr. Thurston if
you could just real quick and he goes
I'll do it once I'll do once and get
your [ __ ] camera out of my face all
echoey these [ __ ] terrible hair all
miked like the fur no the first part was
obviously like and this is super geeky
but the text is a PNG with no background
so you're supposed to be able to put it
over a background but they clearly saved
it as a JPEG I don't so you can see the
transparent background you notice that
oh yeah it's the [ __ ] worst it drives
me crazy every time don't like much of
you yeah I wrap my Windsor there we're
at my window and see you see how in the
background you can see the checkerboard
yeah that's because that's a transparent
background
oh so you're supposed to be able to put
that text just over a black star rather
only listen they save it as a JPEG for a
year as a song then the listening to
explain the JPEG I know I'm not upset by
that
that Rob you get me yeah yeah it's very
annoying let's do this video though I
know that there was an outtake that
nobody remembered that they we didn't
want to do it I figure it was art but
something you decided to do something
alternative make another video yeah
finish this with integrity here's the
and and here's why the text in the
opening is important because the same
person that decided to do that is the
same person that decided on ironically
that the right font for the subtitles in
this video was Comic Sans how do you
know it's come how do I know it's Comic
Sans
you see Comic Sans used on ironically
and you don't sit there and go what the
hell is going on Travis you're with me
on the Comic Sans who knows Comic Sans
worst thank you you guys should all be
sent to Toledo sorry Dan you're so busy
slaying
that you don't understand all this geeks
down sorry that I gotta take time to dry
my dick off to understand one more Jim
and Sam catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM F
[Music]